triple-a is expecting a record 3.8
million Americans will travel by air
during the 4th of July holiday that's an
increase of nearly 8 percent over last
year and with bigger and bigger crowds
at the airports officials at Orlando
International are spending 4 million
dollars on facial recognition technology
the hope is that the new system will
speed up the customs process by
instantly validating a traveler's
identity but as Kris Van Cleave reports
the technology is also raising privacy
concerns these passengers from Scotland
were among the first flyers to be
welcomed to the US by the Orlando
airports new facial recognition system
the airport is the first in the country
to commit to processing all arriving and
departing international visitors with
the technology when they arrive this
system compares their face to their
passport picture in seconds Customs and
Border Protection believes it will speed
up the lines one of the issues is trying
to ensure security at the same time is
and processing people and that seems to
me to do and at the departure gate
travelers leaving the United States
won't have to show their passport
because their face will be their ticket
to board the system compares the photo
it takes against a secured government
database of passport photos those images
will be saved for no more than 14 days
Congress required customs to create a
system using biometrics to track
international visitors exiting the
country we first saw it in action last
September in Boston when customs started
a 13 city pilot program it's proven to
be 99% accurate and can verify a
passenger in about two seconds we really
think we can build a seamless integrated
consistent simplified process to go from
the curb to the gate of the plane and
when you return the plane back to your
car and make it really easy airlines are
interested in biometrics like a face
scan or a fingerprint unique identifiers
that could be a way to replace the need
for a boarding pass
but privacy advocates are worried about
security as we consolidate biometric
data into big databases and we use it
more and more those databases will
become targets in it and the risk of
data breach increases greatly senators
Mike Lee in Edmond
Archy asked customs to halt the
expansion of biometric screening until
security concerns could be addressed
Markey tells CBS News he's quote deeply
concerned about this rollout in Orlando
you know your pictures being taken
you're standing in front of a camera
there's nothing subversive about this
and we're only comparing you against
your passport photo that's the photo
you've already given the government for
travel so simple as that for now US
citizens can opt out and elect to show
their passport prior to boarding an
international flight customs also
announced they'd begin testing facial
recognition for Global Entry users those
who elect to try it will be using their
face as their passport for CBS this
morning Saturday Kris Van Cleave
Washington may be it's how much I travel
anything that makes it faster anything
I've got to the point of take whatever
you want